that's a great backstory
my dream is to win so i can send my my
so my my kid doesn't die from an illness
hello good morning welcome back to
another bonus vlog
video of big mood we are still here in
this airbnb
we just woke up and jess and gina
were talking about how they've been
getting way more into cooking lately and
if you watch their ig stories you could
see
both of these [ __ ] getting very into
cooking
so we thought how about
gina and jess cook us a meal me and tiff
and then we'll judge them and tell tell
you who's the better cook that's not
really much of a meal
but it is a breakfast item i like that i
like that
i don't even know why the [ __ ] i'm even
awake right now for you guys oh i gotta
go put on a bra
to make me food [ __ ] oh okay a short
delay so
we were about to start cooking i was
going to make
um what is it a breakfast quesadilla
since we all over to the airbnb
i just had this app deliver my groceries
for me but they forgot
to deliver cheese what the hell's the
boy sour cream didn't come to right yeah
what's the point of
quesadilla there's no cheese there is no
point and this [ __ ] was like can we
just do it without the cheese and i was
like i think we can go to the store
i didn't want to waste time but then
also jess was like well i mean we're
already wasting time taking [ __ ]
spirit animals
quizzes yeah and we have time we're good
we're good [ __ ] so we're gonna go to
the grocery store and grab some cheese
first and then we'll come home and cook
breakfast at
well it's already 12 15 and 12 15 p.m
yeah
we're pretending like it's breakfast but
it's actually lunch
so it's 12 22. i just let gina off in
the grocery store i honestly feel like
that [ __ ] is going to lottie daw in
there for like 15 minutes i hope not but
with gina she takes forever for
everything so we'll see
while i wait i'm gonna take my animal
spirit quiz and see what i am i'm hoping
for a fox
we'll see what it is just kidding i have
zero [ __ ] internet circle what's
wrong with culver city what the hell
i have no internet in culver city i'm
pissed came out at 12
30 i was so proud of her because i
thought she was gonna dilly dally for a
long time but she did not she came out
really fast and also
i took my spirit animal quiz when we got
back to the house because i didn't have
internet and i was complaining about
that in the car nikki lima oh yeah i got
the snake
and at first i was like ew what the [ __ ]
because i'm not a snake
i'm like these two are year of the snake
snakes
i'm the least snake person ever but sure
i read the thing it was just like
it's the totem source of life or some
[ __ ] maybe you lure guys
into biting your apple i do lower a lot
of biting your ass
a lot of men a ton of it
tips a butterfly because i don't think
i've vlogged i'm actually taking the
quiz right now so i'll find out if i've
changed
okay transformed out of your butterfly
form
i got an owl when you look at the
picture i'm like that [ __ ] looks spooky
as [ __ ]
but then you read it and it's like
excuse me you look like one it's just
your mouth
it was like you're like super wise and
intelligent and
like intuitive and connected and i was
like
[ __ ] yeah i am i'm an owl wait why is
there like a little mini oven is that a
dutch oven i don't know
that's cute as [ __ ] though what is it
it's like for little muffins or
something
how domestic all right cook off are we
starting
the cookoff has commenced yes
the judges are hungry i'm ready i'm
ready let's go let's go let's go
go go go go go we got jess over here
she's got a pot
she's filling it with some water jess
what is your
inspiration behind this pot of water i
don't know but i'm just trying to hurry
because i'm scared i don't want to get
in trouble
it looks like something that's going to
be something gina gina what's that what
you got going
[Laughter]
later at night they're like why is your
dishwasher open
it's a funky party in here can you
imagine i'm just laying there with my
face
you need help just just having trouble
lighting the fires
there's six [ __ ] burners but i'm like
okay where's that one
probably on that side no it's not okay
that's one two three
okay careful
one of them's gotta work oh it's this
one
why isn't that working why do you gotta
pick that one mine you pick one that
already lit
because now i really want this one it's
taunting you now she's just pissed she's
like i wanted this
freaking one the food's gonna suck
no don't say that don't say that a snake
would say that
blaming it all on the burn or not i'm
going to soft boil some eggs
soft boil tonight eggs over here
sausage i won't be eating any of that no
yeah
extra protein i got it i'm gonna just
finger my way in there
okay that's good that's what he said
so nikki can't eat meat so i gotta she's
just gonna cheese quesadilla
okay that's what she's kidding what's up
action's gonna happen fast though
okay well the ed it's all in the editing
editor
editor editor got some egg action
happening
chef caldwell four there's only four
girls
those are all the eggs we have left six
minutes don't [ __ ] up
don't [ __ ] it up no she has a whole
dozen yeah
so much i was talking about in my body
i just finished my quiz yeah and i got
the hummingbird oh
[ __ ] are you no longer transforming then
no it means that it symbolizes the
enjoyment of life and lightness of being
those who have the hummingbird as a
totem are invited
to enjoy the sweetness of life lift up
negativity wherever it creeps in and
express love more fully in their daily
endeavors
that sounds like you after after going
to the transformation
you went from a butterfly to a
hummingbird oh my god i'm cute
and we're both birds
[Laughter]
for all the questions i was like i don't
know somewhat somewhat
somewhat i feel like i need to go back
and think yeah but snakes are very
undulating they're like this they're
like i don't know
maybe yeah i wish i got this thing yeah
i wanted a box i wanted a cat
and i got a [ __ ] bird i like mine yes
suck i love mine
i know you got the best one i got a
whole well actually the hummingbird is
pretty cool blackberry's cute
i gotta blow them i don't know what i'm
saying if we go based off looks because
i feel like i have the bird look
um
[Laughter]
that's what i've been called in my life
what do i look like
because i had some really big gigantic
eyeballs
and your arms are all big yeah i have
really long
arms for my body okay i can see it i
feel like i'm probably a monkey
i like feel like i look like
i was like okay
yeah like a baby panda because she's an
east asian
yeah for sure how cute
with this oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] is this she's plating she's
plating
she's playing wow and i like how it's
alternating
very nice very nice the details thank
you details
she's got what you got what you got
which one uh we're starting on eggs
okay we're starting on the edge i'm
going to set it aside to assemble
please put that in there with no cap
with what didn't have a cap oh okay
okay okay okay no cat that's what the
kids say yeah they do
i don't really know what it means no
lies no no limits
get that sound in there
i should call her feeling a little bit
concerned about the consistency of the
egg because the way they're peeling
i haven't quite figured out the perfect
way to do it yet because i just started
but usually when i do it with one egg it
works but now the way it's peeling it's
like ripping apart and i feel like if
it's perfectly cooked
the peeling comes off easier are you
trying to play yourself down so that we
don't have high expectations
i'm just letting you know that i know
that it's
better than this i don't like what's
happening right you know what all of
your egg no matter what
maybe maybe i think it's good
plating it up [ __ ] mashing this [ __ ]
now i'm gonna get the eggs
let me make a little bed for it oh cute
yeah cut it well well a little well this
is the moment that we've all been
waiting for oh [ __ ]
i'm so ready to be satisfied did it did
i do it right or did i overcook it
i overcooked it oh no oh it still looks
good though
it's all right that's pretty good i'm
not happy with it i like it it's
overcooked
i like a little bit of overcookedness
because i don't like it too ready
it actually looks perfect just licking
your fingers no i'm preparing my food no
i didn't touch it
when i did that i promise
i can't trust the snake the first time i
licked it we're going to put a little
bit of chinese on there
yummy this is not enough seasoning you
can do your own and then some black
pepper
first one is done
gina chef gina how far behind are you
oh what's happening here that's a lot of
things going to put together
but we're getting there getting there we
got our sausages done
how you feeling judge you getting ready
i feel hungry
getting your palate cleansed is your
palate all cleansed
some grapes in my mouth my pellet is
nice and clean the palette cleanser
i'm ready to judge yeah hell yeah i like
judging people
yeah 30 seconds contestants
[Music]
[Laughter]
i have to cut it into small pieces for
my girls because they're bb's
[Laughter]
oh my goodness in these long john
pajamas
she's doing this did you catch me yes
[Laughter]
i used to flirt like that with my cats
when i was alone when i was lived alone
i'd be like
hey frankie why don't you cuddle me
sometime
come over on the big bed excuse me yes
ma'am yes
yes chef yeah 30 seconds third
29
i come from vietnam where uh my mother
was blind and
my son needs help but uh you didn't have
a good sock store you didn't
[Laughter]
that's a great backstory my dream is to
win so i can send my
my so my my kid doesn't die from an
illness so
pick me he's got a really bad illness it
could be they could be saved by winning
why is the cheese not melted
no we're gonna melt it on the pan i see
i think you should do first tasting
while it's still warm you're right
yeah probably already cold to be honest
okay so with the fork
fancy um no i usually just eat it with
my hands
okay so you would you gotta get the egg
and you gotta get all of them in the
same bite i'll do my best
here we go the egg and the avocado and
the toast yeah and the spices
there you ready yes
i want the slow-mo to drip down your
[ __ ] face
okay okay okay okay first impressions
a little too much salt okay i was in a
hurry and i got scared yeah okay yes
you're
rushing i saw that i saw the rushing so
the tony's whatever i think it
alone would have been bomb i like being
salty though yeah
salty ass [ __ ] you salty [ __ ] it's a
little too salty
but you took all of the bite like in one
so i think you got all the salt in one
that's because by the time i know but by
the time like there's there's like
an area of avocado that's not gonna have
salt on it because
i think they all have a different level
of salt like this one's probably not
very salted
yeah they're all different because i
really like the consistency
of the mashed avocado it's not too much
it's not too
chunky okay for your standards you did
overcook the egg a little bit
for me personally i enjoyed it i like it
i like how it's a little bit
not too runny the bread toasted from my
own personal standard
it's a little too toasted yeah that that
one i i toasted twice because the first
time i did it it came out toasted but it
was still white you know when it's like
under toasted still white so i did it
again but i wasn't watching because i
was
still cooking the other you're concerned
with the other things i see i see
i got double top so out of a scale of 10
where would you rate it
a solid 6.5 oh wow that's lower than i
thought i was expecting a six i mean i
was expecting a seven by what you
described
between six and seven so that's why six
point five okay okay six point five six
point five
i would rate it based on how i cook it
up okay and i'm not in a rush
okay okay so we'll see what i think too
but also i usually eat it much faster
and it doesn't sit out
yeah it's true
she likes it you know when you toast
something and
then it gets cold and the toast is like
cold toast yeah so that's what happened
i see timing-wise i personally rate
myself
a 7.7 oh [ __ ] almost an
eight hell yeah okay so
as somebody who used to actually make
this dish every single morning
last year i'll tell you what i rate it
okay i used to put crushed red peppers
on instead of the creole seasoning but
i'm wondering if that kind of gives the
same effect
true i'm gonna put that mud on it's not
spicy
all right guys now i want to talk about
daily harvest it is
so delicious because lately there have
been so many days
where i absolutely forget to eat and
that's not good that's not healthy
so especially when i have like
back-to-back meetings
i'm just like listen i cannot prepare a
whole ass meal for myself
or my husband can't prepare a whole ass
meal for me because he feeds me
so sometimes he's busy and when he is i
turn to daily harvest
so daily harvest delivers delicious food
built on organic fruits and vegetables
right to your door
it just takes a few minutes to prepare
and i never have to question if the food
i'm eating is good for me because they
just use
quality ingredients all natural stuff
it's so delicious my favorite is
actually the carrot and coconut curry
it's the soup and it's just so yummy i
it it's gold it's liquid gold i love it
so
they never use preservatives added sugar
or artificial ingredients and daily
harvest works
works directly with farms to freeze
their ingredients at peak
ripeness to lock in nutrients and taste
with daily harvest is an option for any
time of day
smoothies for breakfast crisp flatbreads
for lunch or dinner
and comfort food for when the weather
starts to cool down like they're
perfectly roasted harvest bowls and
hearty soups
daily harvest is also committed to
minimizing their environmental impact
they're in the process of transitioning
to 100
recyclable plant-based and renewable
fiber packaging
daily harvest makes it easy to eat clean
undeniably delicious food no matter what
your day brings keep it simple with
daily harvest go to dailyharvest.com and
enter promo
code big mood to get 25 off your first
box
that's promo code big mood for 25 off
your first box at dailyharvest.com
that's dailyharvest.com
lots of dollars a lot of doll hairs i
just really like the avocado mixed with
the soft boiled yolks yeah that's good
same thing too yeah
i love when it gets runny all over the
place yeah we waited a little bit till
it got a little cold
so there's them taking that out of the
equation i actually think and i don't
know if it's because it's been sitting
here for a little bit but
my toast is a little under toasted oh
like there's no crunch to it at all yeah
so the timing with the toasting yeah the
toast i mean
a little off but that being said i do
like the way the egg was hooked i don't
think it was
too much under yeah or too much
overcooked i do like a little bit
roundier but
it doesn't it's it's okay yeah i think
mine is under-salted
oh interesting i know i didn't i told
you i didn't
so my yours is over toasted over sausage
yes undertoasted under salted
i do like the seasoning but i wish there
was more of the seasoning i think mine
tastes good
really fast okay just a little bit
some more seasoning that's a lot yeah
that's a lot bro
seasoning the seasoning does have salt
someone feels like
seasoning like has their own level right
true like what you think is not enough
or is too much
might not be the same to nikki
and that's the perfect amount nice so to
me i thought that was
same i thought it was a lot yeah she
likes it good
this is the kind of breakfast that i
would make um that being said i rate it
yeah basically in the middle between you
guys almost i'm a
seven a solid seven maybe i would go a
little bit lower
because the bread is very bland and
under
toasted but if i could have served you
immediately yeah yeah i think it would
have been different
so this part you could see like it was
crunchier yeah but then it might have
gotten
soggy sitting here mm-hmm so i was
tasting it under-toasted
i probably got it for these tools these
are not my tools
lots of variables celebrated to the way
that i want it to be calibrated
uh-oh what's happening over there what's
happening
i have a problem what happened how am i
going to flip [ __ ] with this tiny
[ __ ] thing get the second one and
figure it out
she didn't have her tools i didn't have
my tools exactly
gina's doing like a way more complicated
breakfast which is hilarious because
gina doesn't do anything
true this is like we're on my first date
when you're trying to impress guys
don't [ __ ] cook that man breakfast
make him take you to brunch
we are not cooking for men in this
[Laughter]
until you put a ring on its feet there
we go that's actually how our marriage
worked uh after we got married we
stepped it up
in a big way like steve cleans the whole
house nice
that's how it should be like don't do it
all right we're committed now we're on a
team we're on the same team
yeah amp it up even more all right gina
where you at girl
so the problem is i don't have a big
spatula to flip everything
so i have to cook the top and bottom
separately so this is the top of nicki's
quesadilla this is the bottom i already
grilled the bottom
i already like toasted the bottom so i
have to toast the top and then
slap it all together oh my gosh it's
both of them together yes
that's a gigantic gasoline mm-hmm and
then is that for two people this is for
once you [ __ ] are eating today
do that you [ __ ] are eating today
well you're still gonna cook it
the cheese wasn't melted your zoom is so
slow so it's even
funnier but i'm trying to zoom in on
reactions it's like the slowest
thing ever it's like
[Laughter]
oh my god
also it's hella blurry right now so the
camera's not looking at your
thank you for butt respect camera
yeah because now it's on your face it's
getting clearer this is gina's
concoction look at this cute ass little
sour cream dollop
gina is really trying i know she wants
that ring she's going for it
i don't like cookies i don't clean let
me tell you i got this right
[Applause]
okay that's a lot that's a lot of onions
like onions so don't put tiff don't put
onions on tips and i know that if i get
an extra point
a whole extra point so now she goes up
to like
7.5 now you're at seven point five
points you got something on your lip
girl there you go does she get another
point for that
oh my god
all right chef uh today i i prepared to
you a
mexican inspired dish from ulta
[Laughter]
she gets extra points for performances
she's gonna eat it because the food's
gonna suck oh wow you got haters in your
corner
and then i know that she's got a sick
kid i have as a kid
i have diced vegetables but i know that
chef tiffany doesn't like that so we
will be refraining from eating that uh
we have
appreciate it salt we are going to say
are these organic heirloom
tomatoes organic heirloom tomatoes from
the land of micronesia with sausage
from the finest porks in all the land
micronesia has good porks
oh no
that's racist she said that because i'm
asian she loses a point
oh
smells good you're starting from zero
smells great that [ __ ] is huge and you
didn't cut it you're supposed to kind of
like a pizza minus 10. i don't believe
there were haters
when we were tasting yours jess i need
the help
that's the drama this is such a snake
move right now
[Laughter]
that's true that's true that's a good
point true
let's see now why are you cutting it
like that because i'm cutting it
you lose a point now no one point
no it's like a tiny little like triangle
there we go see
and then you kind of do this like that
switches
[Laughter]
she has a tiny mouth i have a small
mouth look at her
it's a hummingbird the size is about
three centimeters
she's gotta get a tiny bite that's true
this is a big bite
all right
well i like the white stuff around your
mouth
just right on the nose are you emotional
about the background yeah it's so
beautifully done chef thank you chef
okay this is a whole ass meal i love the
sausage tastes great it's a good salty
ratio she got that salt in and the
cheese
it gives it a nice harmonious cheesy
blend
my very first impression that touched my
tongue was with tortillas
the tortilla did have burnt oh burnt
edges
that was the very first thing that i
tasted not pleasant we don't have a
comal in this kitchen
tina gets plus 10 points now you're on
her side
we're against you guys now [ __ ] you
damn [ __ ] i didn't even do anything
yeah
i'm kitchen for you to judge my
tortillas
again i can't go [ __ ] food i haven't
even said anything
tortilla she's cooking on a ceramic pot
not
on a [ __ ] cat garbage this snake this
snake changed size
she changed sides even though it was
burnt like the very first flavor of the
tortilla
was burnt but i liked this meal it's
like a roast
i will give it 8.5 oh
thank you
[Laughter]
yeah you should have planned for that
and y'all ignored me
you guys are going to cut things well i
thought i liked tiff's idea
[Applause]
[Laughter]
thank you oh what are you getting
someone likes my avocados
wow i like that like the salt on the
avocado is so good
yeah that's nice i think this is 7.5 bro
there we go
of course it's still below her i haven't
even had it yet but i give it a two
hating as snake oh what do you think
nikki
that is really good i like that it's
really warm
it's so fresh you know it gets extra
points for that
this combo of flavors is like the most
reminiscent of
breakfast like the hash browns and the
eggs and the cheese and the
portela
[Music]
the same thing happened to me
this sounds mean but i mean i mean it in
the best way it tastes like a mcdonald's
breakfast
that is the most it doesn't
[Laughter]
there we go yeah jess your breakfast is
what i would normally cook for myself
yeah that being said i like to be
treated
i like this treat this was your
ungrateful [ __ ]
i gave you the high-class meal and you
want mcdonald's
you're like you're cat women the cat
doesn't want the cat toys
you want the [ __ ] plastic bag see
don't judge the thing
you don't need to cook well you got that
bomb [ __ ] to lock it down i need to try
all right i haven't heard any lies yet
good job ladies and gentlemen yeah so
good you know
you win [ __ ] gina won excited for your
journeys in the kitchen
this is just i know i just started
cooking too oh i'm proud of
[Laughter]
so now you guys know that jess and i are
very eligible wifeys
you got to earn it right now that's what
i
think
she'll show you all the previews exactly
you could be living like this well there
you go everybody hope you enjoyed the
cookoff we are going to have more bonus
formats for you coming your way
soon so be sure you subscribe greatest
five stars all that [ __ ]
and we'll see you soon yay good morning
good morning good morning buenos dias
[Music]